[Music]
you're quick amanda bynes ketchup
[Music]
amanda has been popping up on Twitter
sporadically over the past year I was
president I wasn't check her out here
posing with a ton of flowers her locks
are super long or her makeup pretty
minimal quote stopping to smell the
flowers on a gorgeous Sunday I'm happy
to be here in February the 31 year old
actress tweeted that someone was
impersonating her online and slammed
marriage and pregnancy rumors that were
started by what she claims is a fake
account there's a higher power that will
judge you for your indecency in August
2016 the actors tweeted about her
infrequent posts quote I've been in
school learning about the fashion
business so I don't have time to tweet I
try to focus on my work few years ago
the former Nickelodeon star began
exhibiting bizarre behavior in 2014 she
was admitted into a treatment center
involuntarily following week she said on
Twitter she had been diagnosed as
bipolar and manic-depressive and said
she was fine
[Music]
you